[Musique]
mais quel ambiance bonjour à tous et à
toutes et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo dans laquelle j'ai fait quatre
jours de randonnée pour vous pour vous
présenter des oeuvres d'art de Land Art
dans la nature et plus précisément les
œuvres de l'artiste Andy qui est un
artiste britannique dont les œuvres sont
souvent réalisées en plein air et
mettent en valeur la beauté et la
vulnérabilité de la nature préparez-vous
un thé mettez-vous bien au chaud sous un
plaid parce qu'aujourd'hui on va
découvrir une randonnée de 150 km avec
plein d'oeuvres d'art à l'intérieur qui
sont in situ dans la nature une
expérience bien sympa qui nous change
des musées la vidéo est en collaboration
avec la région sud aussi un grand merci
au musée Gassendi pour nous avoir
accueillis et surtout un grand merci à
Vincent pour m'avoir supporté pendant
quatre jours dans cette vidéo vous allez
voir des œuvres d'art vous allez me voir
faire de la randonnée donc beaucoup de
beaux paysages mais aussi des œuvres
d'art moi désespéré de paysage moi
désespéré encore et énormément d'oeuvres
d'art mais on va vous expliquer tout ça
on se retrouve à Digne-les-Bains ville
de Haute-Provence dans la PACA mon père
terre natal qui est une ville thermale
reconnue pour ses eaux minérales et ses
sources chaudes depuis l'Antiquité mais
ce n'est pas ça qui nous amène
aujourd'hui à la ville de
Digne-les-Bains c'est le fait qu'elle
soit entourées de paysages naturels
spectaculaire avec notamment la chaîne
de montagnes des Préalpes et la forêt de
Valensole un terrain totalement propice
pour relier une quinzaine d'oeuvres
d'art à travers une randonnée de 150 km
notre premier arrêt est donc la chapelle
Sainte Madeleine petite randonnée c'est
facile et agréable à faire la chapelle
est le premier refuge d'art à avoir été
créé en 2002 il y a eu à l'époque un
malentendu avec la population parce que
c'était une période de sécheresse et il
comprenait pas pourquoi on a les de
l'eau à un type qui était là pour qu'il
fasse des constructions pendant que eux
avaient des restrictions
vous la voyez au bout du chemin la
petite chapelle elle appartenait à la
base à un paysan et il a fallu faire un
échange de terre avec des terres
appartenant la mairie pour que l'artiste
puisse la récupérer
la chapelle à la base c'est une ruine
qui la restaurer lui il aime qu'on passe
du temps avec une oeuvre voire même
carrément dormir avec mais sans le
frapper dans la vidéo un rapport
différent de celui qu'on a en général au
musée
la cavité dans la chapelle c'est ça
l'oeuvre de Andy l'idée c'est que les
gens puissent tenir dedans et qui puisse
laisser une trace de leur empreinte un
souvenir de leur randonnée ce qui est
très important pour l'artiste et j'avais
carrément compris l'exercice sans même
le savoir
effet de FX et pouf
dans la chapelle la seule chose qui fait
vraiment chapelle c'est ce petit hôtel
qui ne fait pas partie intégrante de
l'oeuvre à l'intérieur duquel les gens
ont récupéré des petits bouts de caillou
autour et ont écrit des mots ou des
dessins moi à ce moment-là la seule
chose qui m'a traversé l'esprit c'était
plus égale plus de Lena situations
[Musique]
on dit que le sportif c'est un artiste
marcheur du coup il y a eu tout en
repérage de chemin à travers les
montagnes pour trouver à telle bergerie
abandonnée ça pourrait être sympa ici ou
tel ancienne église etc c'est l'artiste
qui a fait tout seul ce chemin d'oeuvre
d'art de 150 km
[Musique]
si vous avez aimé ce paysage je pense
que vous êtes clairement pas prêt pour
la suite
[Musique]
c'est parti pour un deuxième jour de
randonnée cette fois-ci on commence la
journée par une petite rembour vraiment
celle-ci était très sympa genre pas trop
dur pas trop facile beau paysage
puis au détour de la randonnée on a vu
ces montagnes en mode mille-feuille de
cailloux et on s'est dit mais tiens donc
ah ben oui tiens donc Jean monsieur dame
bah oui à montrer des cailloux comme ça
tu m'as invoqué ça t'apprendra donc ce
qu'on voit ici c'est un truc assez
particulier et assez cool qui s'appelle
une cluse pas une écluse pas François
non plus une cluse en gros le pissou
local a entaillé la roche en plein dans
un pli si c'est bien là si on suit ces
petites strates on le devine le pli et
oui donc ce mille-feuille c'est du
calcaire du calcaire jurassique vieux de
150 millions d'années quand il y avait
un océan à la place des Alpes c'est
l'océan qui a ouvert la Pangée
d'ailleurs et au fond de cet océan se
forment des couches de calcaire en
accumulant notamment les squelettes et
coquilles des bestioles qui mouraient et
qui tombaient au fond et voilà donc ce
qui a donné le millefeuille que vous
avez pu observer et je suis bien
d'accord avec toi alors c'est un peu
beau
après il faut savoir que quand j'ai fait
ces quatre jours de randonnée c'était en
plein mois d'août ce qui est pas le plus
pratique je recommanderais pas de ouf
ouf parce qu'en fait c'est chaud du coup
on devait partir très tôt le matin et
faire les randonnées d'après-midi en fin
d'après-midi pour éviter le fameux midi
16h des enfers
du coup là on est en route vers un des
refuges dans lequel il y a du coup une
oeuvre de l'artiste il faut savoir que
pas mal de refuges sont ouverts accès au
public sans souci et certains sont
fermés à clé et en fait il faut juste
réserver et demander la clé au musée à
samedi ce qui vous donne accès du coup
un refuge dans lequel vous pouvez passer
la nuit pendant vos randonnées
[Musique]
là on voit que mon âme commence à me
quitter mais ce que je ne sais pas ce
moment là c'est que le pire est à venir
si vous voulez faire les randos en
famille ou si comme moi vous n'êtes pas
hyper sportif ou sportive franchement il
y a pas de souci c'est très famili
friendly quoi il y a pas de pas besoin
d'être Tibo inshape ou si simua pour
faire les randonnées il y en a juste une
qui était mais elle je vais vous
prévenir sinon tout le reste est
totalement faisable et il y a pas de
souci à se faire
le panneau qui nous indique qu'on n'est
pas loin du vieil Esclangon et ça c'est
rassurant
nous voilà enfin arrivé au refuge
néanmoins on pensait qu'il faisait
partie des refuges à accès libre et on
n'avait pas pris la clé du coup donc on
a pas su rentrer à l'intérieur mais par
chance on sait voir l'œuvre à travers
les vitres de l'extérieur
on y voit une image qui rappelle le
serpent qui revient très souvent dans
son travail parce qu'il y a cette
symbolique de mouvement et de changement
qui est très important pour l'artiste
loulou dans la contemplation
faut savoir aussi que quand on est
arrivé au refuge avait une famille avec
deux ou trois petits enfants qui avaient
passé la nuit à côté et qui nous ont dit
que ça avait été nuit à la belle étoile
vraiment super très agréable et qu'ils
avaient bien kiffé
10 15 minutes de marche après le refuge
pouvait arriver au sommet dans montagne
pour avoir accès à un paysage incroyable
dont cette montagne à froid avec une
forme circulaire c'est quand même assez
étonnant enfin moi je suis pas
spécialiste des cailloux mais j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment fou mais oui mais oui
c'est fou salut c'est encore moi ce
qu'on voit là c'est un bazar sans nom
facile du coup c'est le vélodrome
d'esclango Vélodrome parce que justement
il ressemble à un circuit de course
cycliste géologues sont des grands
poètes et alors ce qu'on voit là c'est
un pli dans un pli dans un pli je
rentrerai pas trop dans les détails j'ai
pas tout compris moi-même je pense mais
avec la formation des Alpes on a vu
apparaître un premier pli puis un
deuxième pli perpendiculaire au premier
et paf un troisième pli en chapeau
celui-ci qui recouvre les deux premiers
et les unis à jamais je vous ai dit des
poètes et je crois que ce troisième pic
qu'on voit là sans certitude parce que
la géologie des Alpes c'est un vrai bric
à Black et je suis vraiment pas sûr
d'avoir tout compris mais ce qui est
cool c'est que entre le millefeuille de
tout à l'heure et ce vélo de room ces
deux paysages illustrent tout un cycle
tectonique on appelle ça un cycle de
Wilson de la naissance d'un océan à sa
disparition et l'apparition de chaîne de
montagne naissance avec la informations
de nos millefeuilles calcaires qu'on
retrouve aussi ici
disparition avec l'érosion de ces roches
marines pour former toutes celles que
vous voyez là et qu'on appelle des
molasses oui oui c'est leur vrai nom et
érection des Alpes avec notre festival
de plis tel un sharpei et pour la petite
histoire figurez-vous que les Alpes
n'ont pas fini de grandir ça bouge
encore de quelques millimètres par an ce
qui explique pourquoi la région est très
sismique c'est bon je te laisse
continuer ta phrase maintenant et en
fait quand vous faites la randonnée vous
vous rendez compte que les oeuvres elles
sont vraiment pas posées au hasard ce
qui est le cas sont pas posé au hasard
mais on s'en rend compte et ça je trouve
ça vraiment extraordinaire et en fait
l'artiste il allait voir à chaque fois
les bâtissait abandonnés pour voir si
elles étaient dans un contexte qui
allait avec son travail autant
esthétiquement que avec le sens là par
exemple les arrondis de la montagne
rappelle totalement les arrondis sur le
serpent qu'on voit dans le refuge
oui vous l'avez compris il était midi
passé et moi vraiment je suis une enfant
j'ai besoin de manger à midi sinon c'est
la fin du monde pas que je deviendrai
désagréable mais presque
[Musique]
vous reconnaître que c'est aussi quand
même beaucoup plus sympa de descendre la
montagne que de la montée je vous laisse
encore une fois admirer les paysages de
la région de Haute-Provence qui sont un
croyau
on arrive à la randonnée qui m'a achevé
là je fais genre tout va bien mais c'est
complètement
décédé à l'intérieur de moi-même
au bout du rôle il aura fallu pas moins
de 42000 postes pour que j'arrive
jusqu'au refuge du col de l'escouir mais
on y est arrivé
donc là du coup ça fait partie des
refuges où il n'y a pas besoin de clés
parce que comme vous le voyez il y a pas
de porte et vous pouvez aller dormir à
l'intérieur sans souci sans avoir à
prévenir qui que ce soit
ici les oeuvres comme vous pouvez le
remarquer ce sont les murs et donc du
coup les traits blancs sur les murs et
moi au début en fait je pensais que
c'était de la peinture mais en y
regardant de plus près je me suis rendu
compte que pas du tout
et c'est le moment où vous dites mais
lors si c'est pas de la peinture
qu'est-ce que c'est en fait le trait
blanc c'est une formation naturelle dans
la pierre dans le refuge la croix a été
fabriquée parce qu'il a pas réussi à
trouver une croix naturelle mais on
enverra une au musée gassindique on ira
le visiter plus tard dans la vidéo parce
que après coup il a fini par en trouver
une naturelle quoi il s'agit donc de
pierre naturelle qui ont été empilées et
taillées de sorte à ce que les traits
blancs créent des motifs donc on
rappelle il y a plein de cailloux dans
la nature il est allé voir les cailloux
et il allait chercher ce qui avait des
traits blancs il les a récupérés taillés
et il a fait ses formes ce qui comme
vous le comprenez il y a un travail en
amont qui est quand même assez
conséquent après il est pas tout seul le
tipari une équipe qui travaille avec lui
derrière mais voilà c'est quand même mon
gros travail de recherche
et là présentement ce que vous êtes en
train de regarder c'est ce qui m'a tué
c'est ce qui a littéralement aspiré
toute l'âme de mon corps et qui m'a
laissée inerte sur le sol c'est cette
montée avec un dénivelé de zinzin je
t'ai pas prête psychologiquement il faut
savoir que c'était la première fois de
ma vie que juste je faisais des
randonnées je sais pas non plus la GO la
plus sportive de la planète donc là
vraiment moi pour moi c'est de monter et
même dans la descente je me sentais moi
je l'ai vécu comme du 90 degrés donc je
me sentais comme les petites chèvres là
vous avez qui marche sur les rebords des
montagnes même ressenti je pense que
c'est pas ça du tout mais
psychologiquement dans ma tête c'était
le même ressenti donc je dirais que
celle-ci elle est si une randonnée
peut-être un petit peu plus difficile ou
alors c'est vraiment moi qui suis un
caca mais Vincent aussi est un beau goût
du rôle
pour ce jour 3 on va découvrir un
nouveau type d'oeuvres qu'il y a sur le
parcours qui sont les sentinelles et en
tout il y en a trois début 2000 il a
fait les kernes donc les œufs en pierre
que vous voyez à la base les cairns
c'est comme des gardiens de la route des
protecteurs de la route et à l'époque
ben ça a pas été spécialement bien
accueilli non plus les habitants de
Hotton ont pas trop compris la démarche
par exemple il comprenait pas pourquoi
les pierres venaient pas de chez eux
elle venait de Sisteron un autre village
du coin moi personnellement je pensais
que comme ça s'installait parfaitement
dans le paysage ça s'intégrait vraiment
super bien je pensais que c'était passé
crème mais les habitants ils sont dit
mais pourquoi un artiste anglais qui
habite en Écosse qui est dans le sud de
la France fait des cairn chez nous il y
a eu tout plein d'explications qui ont
été faites de la part de l'artiste et de
son équipe ils ont fait énormément de
réunions pour expliquer le pourquoi du
comment peu après les habitants ils ont
compris et c'est quand même stylé en
fait
des plus grands artistes du land art
s'installent dans la région par exemple
d'un point de vue touristique faut
savoir que pour l'artiste
Digne-les-Bains et sa région c'est pas
juste n'importe quel endroit en France
alors oui sa résidence principale est en
Écosse à Paimpont mais il a aussi une
résidence secondaire à diminuer les
Bains c'est une région qui lui tient à
cœur et qu'il aime énormément ce qu'il a
embêté au début de son projet c'est que
les sentinelles soient reliés par la
route comme je vous l'ai dit lui c'est
un artiste marcheur mais il s'est rendu
compte que les 3 sentinelles parce qu'en
tout il y en a trois elle correspondent
à trois vallées dinoies qui pouvaient
communiquer entre elles à travers des
chemins de randonnée du coup c'est pour
ça qu'il a fait à la base tout le chemin
avec ces plusieurs randonnées pour
relier les sentinelles puis les refuges
là vous me voyez tourner autour de
l'oeuvre parce qu'en fait je voulais
mettre aussi mon petit caillou pour
participer à l'oeuvre car il faut savoir
que quand même l'artiste a fait son
œuvre on se rend compte en l'étudiant de
près et en regardant les détails que
les gens aussi ont inséré des petits
cailloux ici et là et je voulais moi
aussi participer à l'oeuvre
[Musique]
c'est reparti pour une nouvelle rando
cette fois-ci on va vers la ferme de
long qui sera notre refuge pour la nuit
encore une fois nouvelle randonnée
nouveau paysage
[Musique]
il faut savoir que la ferme Belon c'est
un ancien lieu de la résistance on a vu
que des fois ça se passe pas vraiment
super bien de prime abord avec les
habitants mais cette fois-ci ce sont eux
qui sont venus directement voir
l'artiste parce qu'il voulait mettre en
avant ce côté de leur histoire
il cherche des lieux qui ont une
empreinte une âme une histoire pour leur
donner une nouvelle vie
la ferme Belon elle est sur deux étages
les arches qui sont l'oeuvre d'art sont
à l'étage inférieur
pour lui c'était important d'installer
les arches dans la cave parce que
c'était une façon de penser aux
résistants qui s'y cachait ça vous
permet aussi de voir l'intérieur dans
des refuges comme ça vous voyez ce qu'il
y a dedans c'est assez rustique mais bon
vous avez de quoi dormir une cheminée
tout ce qu'il faut quoi
alors depuis ma bord comme ça un peu
glauque ça l'était encore plus en vrai
mais let's go dans la cave pour
découvrir les arches il faut savoir
qu'on partage aussi la ferme le refuge
avec des chauves-souris il y en avait
pas mal autant dans la cave que à
l'étage du coup nous quand on y est
resté on n'a pas allumé les lumières
pendant la nuit histoire de pas trop les
déranger mais du coup voilà vous vous
baladez dans une cave avec ses arches de
pierre
[Musique]
encore une fois je le redis mais les
paysages sont extraordinaires on est là
au milieu de rien et on entend rien du
tout on est vraiment tout seul dans la
forêt hyper agréable hyper reposant
[Musique]
mais bon après trois jours de randonnée
je suis un peu décédée et comme vous le
voyez à ma tête mon âme ne m'a pas
seulement quittée elle a pris ses
cliques et ses claques et elle m'a dit
je reviens plus jamais
du coup on se retrouve au point
d'origine de la vidéo ou en fait c'était
durant notre soirée dans le refuge
beaucoup de prises qu'on doit refaire
beaucoup d'échecs parce que la fatigue
se fait sentir et je suis au bout du
rôle mais toujours là pour avoir pensive
tout en écrivant des trucs et en buvant
monter chaud dans un refuge éclairé à la
bougie au milieu de nulle part on kiffe
quand même
et le soleil se lève sur le jour 4
dernier jour de notre périple tout est
toujours aussi beau aussi calme et aussi
agréable la nuit fut très chaude j'ai eu
extrêmement chaud les chauves-souris
n'étaient pas si dérangeantes que ça
[Musique]
et après un petit déj ben on refait le
sac on accroche le sac de couchage et on
repart dans l'autre sens parce qu'il y a
encore d'autres petites choses à faire
cette randonnée aussi était super facile
c'est majoritairement du plat les doigts
dans le nez en vrai la seule difficile
c'est celle que qui m'a tué mais sinon
tous les autres en vrai elles sont
totalement faisable et surtout cela
c'est vraiment du plat et ça fait partie
des paysages que j'ai préféré ça faisait
vraiment genre Grand Canyon tout noir
c'était très joli et du coup oui si je
devais noter les randonnées que j'ai
faites enfin du moins les paysages je
dirais que celle-ci aura été ma préférée
[Musique]
on est allé visiter le musée Gassendi
qui documente tout le travail qu'a fait
Andy goldsorcy au sein de la région et
c'était super d'avoir toutes ces
informations après avoir vu toutes les
œuvres comme ça on a eu plein
d'explications notamment par exemple les
traits blancs sur les cailloux le
pourquoi du comment il y a évidemment
énormément de photos qui documentent
tous les processus pour toutes les
œuvres au musée il y a aussi ce serpent
le ce qui a un paysage fait de terre qui
est une oeuvre de Andy goldorcy ou
encore une fois il réunit sa région
natale en Écosse avec la ville de
Digne-les-Bains et en fait la terre qui
a été choisie l'argile vient pas de la
région mais pour donner un côté ok je
travaille avec la population le Liang a
été utilisé c'est des cheveux comme vous
pouvez le voir avec ce gros plan des
cheveux récupérés dans les salons de de
Digne-les-Bains
l'omancie n'est autre que Pierre
Gassendi lui-même qui est un philosophe
mathématicien et astronome français du
XVIIe siècle très important pour la
ville de digny-les-bains parce qu'il est
à l'origine d'énormément de choses dans
le musée vous trouverez aussi une
section d'art contemporain et d'arts
ancien vraiment si vous avez le temps
aller y faire un tour le musée est super
[Musique]
dernière étape et dernière randonnée de
cette vidéo qui est d'ailleurs aussi la
randonnée la plus facile de toutes comme
vous le voyez les paysages sont encore
une fois totalement différents
[Musique]
ce refuge d'art est lui aussi totalement
accessible sans avoir de clés quoi que
ce soit vous pouvez y aller et le
visiter
l'artiste dira de se refuge en un sens
les cairns situés à l'intérieur des
maisons deviennent les jalons de la
marche et des monuments à la mémoire de
ceux qui ont autrefois vécu ici marcher
sur les anciens sentiers qui étaient
autrefois les routes principales reliant
les villages entre eux communiquent le
sentiment très fort de l'énergie et de
la vie qui existait autrefois dans les
villages aujourd'hui en ruine situé
là-haut dans des montagnes et par la
même évoque peut-être en retour la
précarité et la fragilité de nos vies
vous voyez dans ma tête que je suis très
rassurée parce qu'en fait j'avais
énormément de toiles d'araignées et
voilà on est un peu un peu fragile par
ici mais bon très sympa est-ce que j'ai
bien aimé en fait ici c'était le temps
comme le temps avait fait son temps sur
l'oeuvre entre les toiles d'araignées
les packs des gens et tout
c'est vraiment une approche totalement
différente de quand on va au musée où
tout est hyper léché il faut rien
approcher c'est très aseptisé en soi là
vraiment il y a le temps il a roulé sur
l'oeuvre les gens ont roulé sur l'oeuvre
parce que c'est pas protégé si on veut
prendre un petit caillou mettre un petit
caillou on fait ce qu'on veut et ce qui
est très agréable avec ses refuges d'art
et les œuvres à l'intérieur c'est qu'en
fait c'est très contemplatif tout est
fait pour qu'on s'assoit qu'on se pose
qu'on profite du paysage qu'on regarde
l'oeuvre qu'on s'interroge qu'on
s'interroge pas on fait ce qu'on veut
c'est vraiment très agréable et très
relaxant
bon après on oublie pas les réseaux
sociaux quand même un petit story par ci
une petite story par là
en tout cas j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu un grand merci encore une
fois à la région sud et au musée
Gassendi nous avoir permis de vous
montrer toutes ces randonnées moi par
exemple je suis de la région et je
savais même pas qu'il y avait ça à côté
donc si vous aussi vous êtes dans la
paka n'hésitez pas à aller faire un tour
si vous y passez cet été en vacances ou
peut-être cet hiver ou n'importe quand
et si vous avez envie d'une petite
balade dans la nature contemplative avec
des oeuvres d'art ici et là n'hésitez
pas et foncer c'est vraiment une
expérience à faire
[Musique]